on his podcast bro o'malley sean  o'malley reacted to rumors that jake  paul could be fighting internet  personality andrew tate next paul has  been actively looking for a fight on  social media since his bout with haseem  kramen jr fell through a bout between  paul and tate would bring together two  of the internet's most polarizing  figures logan paul hints at andrew  taver's jake paul next day  um the way andrew tate hits mitts it's  hard to say entertains hands down for  boxing might not be good for against  jake paul jake paul's you know been  boxing consistently over the years  setting up his right hand jabber to the  body you know entertains been smoking  cigars [ __ ] [ __ ] and and hit mitts  every once in a while so i think that  would not be a good night for andrew  tate if i had a gas kickboxing it's  different i've never really seen  anything kickbox but it adds a different  element to it